hello and welcome to this video playing
I am tactic tactic water tactic return
no no way I'm going to pronounce that
correctly was the name Melchior comet
khong kata neck while William issues
with names ok what is mr. tactic
something playing him he has some
English opening two regions post into
that this is an interesting way to play
with Bishop to e7 it's not very popular
but quite interesting I have a special
idea against this this is what I found
while preparing my English opening video
series for chess 24 which is not a well
maybe with this video when this video is
published it is released I don't know
the time of recording it is not yet
released but it's in the works it seems
they still have to do some things with
it I oh no no ok look 28 so he covers
this do at TKE now this is we'll see
we'll see you this is leading to do
something so long castle so it's a bit
strange or strange uncommon let's say
maybe the only thing that does a bit
off-putting is the weakness of the f 2
square what will seem now i have three
threatened sir Knight takes d5 I think
yeah maybe just be sure to see cell okay
so 94 looks like the most normal move on
anything else now this looks like the
way to go
am I going to play this with some f3 I
guess yeah the bishop 1g to sm not doing
all that much that's interesting
interesting way to activate this app
looks good rocky three maybe nope didn't
do that okay so kind of stepping in a
penny of it centralizing I cannot be
that bad so now how do we play for
something here it's not all that easy
hmm I can try a c5 and Bishop c4 maybe
not sure about this laughter King f7
this makes a little bit more sense now
it's we strongly okay him don't think
that i get i got anything special here
or anything at all i don't know it feels
like you should be okay and threatens
rookie seven so okay so we go into the
minor piece ending unless i'm playing
worked you one but that looks wrong so
let's take it so you should hear doesn't
do much so let's go
to this square maybe equals Bishop
before trying to exchange or this one
it's a similarly focus move okay I'm
taking this do I go see five before now
maybe maybe yeah it's probably something
to try maybe I can play em to make his
Bishop look a little bit questionable
but he tries to wriggle himself out of
this I can just take it's not not doing
all that much yeah keep it should be six
that was a good defensive move I guess
so 95 going to take and try to bring the
King around check came
skin III and stuff
yeah if i take it hmm I cannot go King
III am I have to take unfortunately yeah
this is not enough to to get anything
anything going it goes g5 I can take an
hd2 h4 maybe but still then this should
be a draw should be a draw we're very
slight symbolic here let's say advantage
but it's nothing that should mean
anything mmm a4 b5 okay let's try
something so be five
you can go a 5 D 6 Bishop takes a for
Bishop a 6 an idea that I that I trying
for which assisted risky of course maybe
it doesn't really work out all that well
85 is the thing be 16 to do seven maybe
I can go like g4 it could be okay place
it in a conservative way so check here
too now that doesn't do anything so
Bishop c4 is drawn time warning checker
can check in here and then okay I'm
covering this so maybe i can bring the
King around fishery 6 is not such a
simple to play ok so I'm not entering
and I cannot enter ok
it's still very druish check check hmm
take it from this side mini we should do
g2 ok ok nan looking at this porn so
maybe i can bring the King around now
glass forfeits on time yeah King before
and so on I'm not sure it's probably a
draw but I can can come around down can
always try around it's probably a draw
of course it wasn't mostly I wanted to
go here but you can probably come around
like this again King the eighth there
should be 16 c7 and I can go go like
this adds probably a draw it's probably
wrong um yeah he defended this precisely
i guess maybe he takes you five is a
little bit too lame but again i still
thought i could try a things and i think
it's also quite well defended p 8 yeah
that's all good a good defense into here
this is just not enough to do much I
mean he has this structurally slightly
questionable bishop but it's really just
slightly questionable especially with
coming out to d5 it's it shouldn't be
all that much now now it's probably a
draw ok well thanks for watching